sembrar corales en el caribe eso es lo
que está haciendo yo hoy ver un joven de
20 años que nació en isla fuerte
colombia
y trabaja con la organización por
ocurrir en el propósito de reconstruir
el 25 por ciento de los arrecifes que ha
perdido el lugar una perdida que se ha
acelerado con el calentamiento de las
aguas por la crisis climática
quisiera tener como una oportunidad va a
aprender también más aunque sea un
poquito pero no mucho
quisiera que aprender más poco más de
coral tres más uno lo cría para pese
llega más más turista y hoy ver trabaja
con todos los isleños lo conocen como
creo que es este vio luego lleva más de
dos décadas investigando en la isla y
todos los años lleva a sus alumnos desde
bogotá para indagar más sobre el mar y
sus especies su labor ha sido la base
científica de la siembra de coral que
comienza con la recolección en las
praderas marinas
y dentro de esa zona de pastos hay un
montón de fragmentos de coral
no tienen oportunidad de vivir en esos
pastos van a terminar perdiendo la pelea
por la luz porque los pasos que están
aquí el equipo se adentra al mar para
escoger los corales una vez vuelven al
puerto seleccionan las partes vivas un
proceso que llama la atención de
turistas y locales
los arrecifes de coral serán las casas
de la mayoría de los animales que
comemos pescados que comas por ti
ahora descargo
la cara ustedes aprendan a cuidar ya no
dañarlos es fundamental porque eso lo
que nos va a ayudar
los corales sobre ir en las comunidades
van a tener comida de por día otra de
las grandes ventajas de los corales es
que protegen a las costas del oleaje y
la erosión además son unos magníficos
catadores de dióxido de carbono
a diferencia del árbol que cuando cae se
descompone es cuando cae cuando cae se
rompe se fragmenta y se convierte en
arena pero no libera el carbono entonces
finalmente duran miles de años en el
carbono retenido en las estructuras
a pesar de lo mucho que sirve para
combatir la crisis climática los
científicos del ipcc estiman que entre
el 70 y el 90 por ciento de los corales
del mundo se perderán si el planeta se
calienta 1.5 grados celsius más por eso
en isla fuerte los siembran y así
también contribuyen al arrecife más
grande que hay en occidente el
mesoamericana
[Aplausos]
mirando los patrones de corrientes de
los vientos alisios que generan los
vientos alisios y la contracorriente del
darién somos exportadores de larvas a
los arrecifes que están en san andrés
providencia y centroamérica es decir
inclusive toda la toda la barrera
arrecifal de mesoamericana entonces
conservar la fuerte es mantener el
aporte de material biológico para llevar
de manera natural a estos otros
arrecifes
después de la siembra llega el monitoreo
para verificar si lo trasplantado logra
sobrevivir a los blanqueamientos la
mayor amenaza que enfrentan los corales
del mundo por el calentamiento de las
aguas con los datos julián puede llevar
el proyecto al mercado para buscar
dinero a los mecanismos con un script o
monedas y turismo para pensar arrecifes
y dos opciones financieras el primero
son mecanismos de deuda que en colombia
apoyados por la taxonomía verde una
forma de clasificar proyectos con
impacto se ayuda a esto también el
sector financiero nos permite
desarrollar productos más directos hacia
el consumidor final por ejemplo tarjetas
de crédito tarjetas débito que parte de
los digamos de las transacciones que se
realizan con las tarjetas se destinan a
estos proyectos
y por primera vez en américa latina y el
caribe las empresas que tienen o quieren
compensar sus impactos ambientales
pueden hacerlo comprando créditos de
biodiversidad en el que un crédito
equivale a apoyar un metro cuadrado de
arrecife restaurado la idea es tan
novedosa que la respalda south point una
organización internacional dedicada a
impulsar iniciativas que reduzcan el
dióxido de carbono este proyecto es un
hito en américa latina y el caribe es el
primer proyecto que funciona bajo
esquemas agregados de compensación en
ecosistemas marinos digamos bajo ese
nombre específico nos da mucha confianza
financiera de sostenibilidad y algo muy
importante y es la participación de las
comunidades para nosotros
digamos trabajar en un ambiente como es
la fuerte es clave porque nos da la
posibilidad de atraer a las diferentes
personas que habitan la isla y con los
habitantes sembrando arrecifes y
enseñándole a los turistas los corales
de isla fuerte se fortalecen para luego
viajar por el cario
[Aplausos]